pour se creuser la tête avec studio va
qu'on ait vraiment envie de faire une
vidéo ensemble tous les 3 pourquoi je
suis en tension tu as le stress de
devoir réaliser un effet de mentalisme
de magie je ne sais pas à quelle
solution tu vas prendre pour mentaliser
notre ami cyril c'était ton envie à toi
tu es tu m'as dit à peu près ce que tu
voulais faire je vais connaît bien du
coup c'est un peu bizarre de faire ça
mais cyril grâce à fabien j'ai réussi à
prendre quelques petites techniques
je vais tenter de deviner une chanson
par ministe que je viens de concocter un
instant manu chao el corazon attentes à
5 secondes pour choisir une de ses
chansons
voilà maintenant tu vas te la nature et
la chanter dans ta tête mais j'ai ma
petite idée
je pense que c'est daft punk c'est pas
mal jamal en vrai dire ici alors nous on
va faire quoi parce que je pense qu'on a
perdu notre chaîne claude chance je vais
vous faire le montage en une minute ont
récemment bon je parle on a une minute
in de la vidéo exactement et là on a
onze minutes 30
alors qu'on avance minute trente au
compteur alors on cherchait tout à
l'heure un truc pour pour pour faire
tout ça ensemble
voilà ce que je proposais que toi tu
fasses des choix que je déduis ensuite
ses choix dans le posant des questions
et que au lieu de les révéler mais
conclusions j'essaye d'influencé thomas
à reproduire les mêmes choix que toi et
après qu'on compare pour deux actes pour
voir si ça un marché si jeune et si j'ai
réussi en fait à être l'espèce de pivot
entre vous la plaque tournante de votre
drogue neuronale jamais dit une phrase
on s'attarde est le type de la vidéo
cyril jeter dessiner ici regardez ça
ccir et tu te reconnais je vois
milliards encore lâche encore là alors
j'ai pas fait les flexions des genoux on
nous a parlé mais je ne savais pas où
passent dans la rue il y a des pieds un
pantalon une ceinture un os et veste je
fais la capuche et un chapeau tu vas
tout colorier de la tête aux pieds
d'accord donc d'abord le chapeau en
dessous des t-shirts ensuite à ceinture
ensuite les
le pantalon et pour terminer les pieds
moi je vais je n'ai pas de capuches
c'est ridicule ce que je me fais un gain
de faire ça je n'ai pas de cap pas de
talent bon je fais ça et même je me mets
comme ces raccords d'accord comme ça tu
peux témoigner de l'asie fait ton
chapeau jeu givet d'entrée huawei en ce
sens que tu ne m'influence nullement ce
n'est pas à toi de faire ce petit
travail
il fait ton petit chapeau c'est pas soit
bien colorier ou six mois tant qu'à
faire je les amis j'accélère fait quand
même un bon montage la base de coloriage
j'ai envie que les gens ils ont appliqué
sur
[Musique]
alors vous allez voir c'est
extraordinaire j'ai eu un coup c'est
peut-être ça me rassure usage mais j'ai
eu un coup de paniers de me dire je
monte le truc et ça tombe bien thomas en
face je n'étais pas dans 10 à kraft peut
regarder sans risque de voir tous ces
bons moments
ouais bon et bd c'était formidable une
micro sieste un machin tu fais mal aux
yeux en fait j'ai quelques questions
proposées
néanmoins des questions auxquelles tu
vas devoir me répondre par exemple là je
vais te demander de faire des réponses
mais que dans sa tête sans les
verbaliser
d'accord on peut dire que la tombe où il
est plutôt ouvert et je pense que du
coup t'as pas voulu faire ça en verre ça
peut se comprendre d'ailleurs que tu dis
ce serait trop simple
néanmoins si t'as pas fait ça envers ma
théorie et ne cherche pas de l'été
l'indicé calé sur la couleur la plus
proche du ver est dans le vide du genre
juste avant le verre on a levé le verre
du genre c'est le clou juste avant le
verre on à libé quelle bleus pour moi ya
de fortes chances que tu sois allé sur
le bleu ici de la même manière
psychologiquement un homme quand il doit
faire un choix spontané que pas
forcément sa couleur au cocasse la
première couleur qui prendra c'est comme
danone ou deux thèses marteau rouge
qu'ils investissent la bbc un forçage
psychologique qu'on utilise pour faire
penser que quelqu'un à quelqu'un un
marteau et la couleur rouge que c'est la
première chose qui nous viennent
spontanément à l'esprit parce qu'on a
toujours été correct en rouge les choses
importantes sont rouges intermittents
roja passion et en rouge le sang et en
rouge et ses experts donc ya de fortes
chances pour moi que le chapeau soit
rouge
si c'est le cas si j'ai bon là dessus ça
veut dire que j'ai bon sur la suite
en tout cas j'ai une théorie sur les 3
derniers puisque plus on avance il
approuve moyens
toi donc je te remercie pour toutes ces
réponses non verbale que tu m'as donné
bien malgré toi et je pense j'ai quand
même un doute
du coup pour le suit mais se poseront
donc de chapeau et rouge maintenant je
vais essayer de les retransmettre
d'accord pareil au même et souvent d
influence notre ami la maintenance et la
mer je vais essayer de te parler et de
faire faire des choses sans regarder moi
même le résultat final c'est parti je
retourne dans mon antre du je ne vois
rien quand je vais claquer des doigts tu
vas prendre une couleur qui n'est pas ta
couleur préférée
maintenant tu fais le pantalon de sylt
étaient tous pantalon est ce que tu peux
prendre la couleur que tu aimes le moins
dans tes mains s'il te plaît alors que
j'aime le manga vendeurs qui t'inspire
et moi que tu aimes le moins qu'on a une
couleur que tu aimes le moins à quoi tu
l'as tu l'as débouchés tu fais tout
chapo le petit chapeau qui est en haut
ça marche donc ses futurs bouche et tu
prends le temps de la réflexion de dire
le prochain coup c'est cette couleur là
que j'aimerais prendre des points ok tu
as fait le choix mentalement - alors
prendra maintenant physiquement mais là
ce n'était pas spontanée c'était un truc
de tout réfléchi quoi tout enseignant et
es-tu coloris de la petite ceinture là
c'est juste au dessus du pantalon
je prends la couleur qui préfèrent alors
sur les deux c'est bon ouais tout le tee
shirts et ce qui l'est c'est ce qui se
faisait de plus longs ouais c'est ce que
tu as compris qu'avec le dernier flotte
tu ferais le chapeau non tu vient de
lâcher leur récente est une blague
les chaussures les chaussures et
remarques je vais te donner un petit
truc
ah si je ne me suis pas trop trompé dans
un arrêté ont des chapeaux et des
chaussures dorées
c'est possible c'est pour moi trop ok
donc ça derby ou pas alors cyril te
retourne pas niveau coloriage un peu
moreau tourner c'est pas terrible mais
l'intention est là alors toi t'as fait
ça
bon les yeux défoncé là mais tu sais ce
café ciel ou pas enfin nombre à vue sont
des sandales et moi j'ai pas vu ça c'est
fort mais là ce que je peux dire c'est
qu'au moins tout ce que je voulais faire
avec toi c'est ce qui s'est passé pas de
preuve de ça tu vois un message c'est
exactement ce que je voulais d'accord
tant besoin
ok je te crois mais ce que je voulais
faire c'est exactement ça alors
maintenant si c'est la même chose qu'il
a fait on peut me croire si c'est pas la
même chose tu seras jamais si ses cinq
voleurs ici à tous c'est pas ça que je
veux mais je dis ça comme ça au cas où
ce serait même jour quel est ce que tu
peux revenir avec nous s'il te plaît et
sortir ton magnifique coloriage à ce
championnat 12e c'est déjà ce que tu
voulais faire naître et que déjà servi
entre chaleur c'était bon ce que je te
disais thouaré oui ok ok a priori on
n'est pas trop mal à saisir en fait
choisi c'était tellement chaud ce qu'on
voulait faire
qui aurait voulu grandes chances que ce
soit raté
10 en rigolant je ne savais pas si on
est le publions pas quoi j'ai
l'impression de presque pas avoir
réfléchi c'est bien moi j'ai senti mon
influx j'ai senti une influence tu vois
quand même et c'est normal
ce qui m'a fait tiquer c'est que ce
stylo orange ouais très différent des
autres et en fait je me suis dit c'est
quoi cette couleur j'avais pas lu aussi
j'adore mais oui à la en fait le par la
petite explication c'est qu'il est mort
l'autre jour et du coup j'ai cherché à
racheter des cds crayola allez trouver
des big décor à l'eau je me suis aperçu
qu'ils colorent follows très bien plus
vous connaissiez studio vrac alors c'est
bien abonnez vous ne connaissiez pas
studio braque alors c'est bien
abonnez vous je pense que cette
influence était assez subliminal oui
parce que l'intérêt découvrir votre
chaîne j'espère que ça va aussi bien
marché que nous influencer pour votre
message social il ya à peu près tout ce
que vous ferez partie des délais indus
une vidéo par jour sur studio vrakking
durant tout 2010 cette voie là j'en
viens au 8 décembre
ils prennent le relais de mon défi je
leur confie comme ça c'est des bravo les
mecs je voulais vous féliciter
je suis le prix temps je vais prier
certes il a fait chaud mais j'ai pris
mes
c'est tellement drôle que je fasse une
passation de défis comme ça difficile
parce que nous on est plutôt une vidéo
par mois le prochain sont enfin de ce
qu'on est en train de rire ça sort très
bientôt ouais ouais court métrage qui
sort très bientôt la volée voir abonnez
vous au moins tant qu'ils sortent
voilà une loi ni les artistes
partez-vous eux-mêmes - puis on fera on
essaiera de faire une vidéo avec toi
très prochainement sur la chaîne pour
continuer parce que comme vous le verrez
certainement moins bien moi non pas
moins bien mais moins tout court oui
vous allez d'invasion 2017 si la vidéo
vous a plu comme d'hab vous vous abonner
et boulic et rendez vous demain à 11h
ciao ciao
[Musique]